and finally new rule everyone has to
admit that even though Bernie Sanders
didn't win the nomination he's already
won the future now last week in this
space I talked about how socialism was
something America needs more of to
curtail capitalism because the profit
motive creates horrible incentives like
keeping people sick putting too many of
them in jail always being at war and
treating a woman touching Donald Trump's
air as breaking news
but let's not romanticize socialism the
way conservatives romanticize capitalism
these are economic systems not your
first kiss so if you say
if you say the word socialism to people
under 40 the reaction is night and day
from that of baby boomers for whom
socialism has always been seen as
communism zag a cousin but for
Millennials the word socialism doesn't
conjure up images of Stalin and Castro
it conjures up images of naked Danish
people on a month-long paid vacation
Millennials don't remember a threatening
Soviet Union or any Soviet Union the
only time they've ever had to crouch
under a desk was to go down on their
teacher so so the new generation is
ready for socialism problem is they may
be ready for a little too much socialism
almost two-thirds of Sanders voters want
free college and free universal health
coverage for no more than an extra
thousand dollars in taxes even though
that's not really socialism that's Santa
isn't
and look no one is arguing that
Millennials haven't gotten a rotten deal
in this economy but they've also gotten
too used to getting [ __ ] for free we
we've accepted that the new normal in
America is people in their 20s and even
30s still on their parents cell phone
plans and health care plans and mom and
dad's still paying the car insurance and
almost a third of them are still living
at home and if you're a millennial you
may never have known the concept of
paying for things that all of us used to
pay for I'm a baby boomer I think the
natural order of things
is to pay for music I like
to do less than that doesn't make you a
revolutionary it makes you the person
who goes to the bathroom when the check
comes ha ha and it's not just music
pornography I was still in my prime
masturbating years when when porn became
free and I saw how it decimated a proud
industry that once produced full-length
features with plots and pubic hair and
just like with musicians the men and
women of the adult industry who
entertain and diverged and yes released
million millions of Americans every day
deserve to be paid for what they do
think about the long hours put in by
horny housewives and naughty secretaries
and the hard-working shaved head
dead-eyed meth addicts plowing them
they're doing it for shits and giggles
that costs extra
what haha when I hear about people
stealing porn I have one question where
do you get off porn doesn't just happen
people locations must be scouted sets
must be sets must be built wood must be
maintained the point is if you add up
all the free things that the under-40
crowd is used to getting from the quick
jerk at work to being able to sit in
Starbucks all day for the price of a
scone from music to Wi-Fi to birth
control it's not such a jarring
proposition when socialism comes along
and says you are entitled to free stuff
and that in turn must be why there's
this proliferation of websites like
Kickstarter and GoFundMe GoFundMe go
fund yourself
you